what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into Justice
League no justice part deuce support
part dos purdue's this is this is
shaping up to be a pretty solid story I
mean this this is really really awesome
again it's the same thing we said in the
beginning in the last video when it
comes to Scott Snyder he's one of those
guys where he can write anything and it
always turns out to be good like I've
never been disappointed by anything
Scott Snyder's ever written like I've
never read and just kind of been like it
was okay like like his I mean everything
he touches his gold she's also a really
cool guy to talk to
ah but with Justice League no justice
this is one of those cool situations
because initially this kind of turned
out or at least it seemed on its surface
to be this story where DC was just like
introducing Omega Titans which was like
DC's version of the Celestials and
Galactus combined it's like a singular
set of beings but this really seems to
be more world-building than anything
else adding a lot more stuff into the
realm of DC but what we talked about in
the last video is that you would
essentially have like a version of
Brainiac that had shown up on earth and
basically grabbed all the earth
superheroes and then whisked them off to
the far side of the universe to
basically the planet colu which is the
home planet of Brainiac himself and the
result was that he basically said there
are these being beings called Omega
Titans when you guys broke the source
wall the wall at the edge of the
universe
these are mega Titans came through and
now they're basically traveling from
planet to planet and they're going to
essentially destroy them on depending on
which aspect of the Omega Titans the
planets more conducive to that's the way
this this unfolds now of course again
we'll get more into that as we get
through this video but the idea was that
because there was a source wall and like
Amanda Waller didn't know about it the
federal government of the United States
didn't know about it her response was
well what else are they hiding and so
what they ended up doing or what she
ended up doing was grabbing the best
psychics all across the entire landscape
of the DC Universe or at least on earth
channeling all their energies and
basically breaking into the mind of
Brainiac when he had taken their
superheroes to his home planet and in
the process of doing so while she did
learn a lot of the secrets Brainiac had
she also basically destroyed him and so
the result is that Earth's superheroes
are basically stuck on colou with no
real idea of what it is that they're
doing and so in response to this Amanda
Waller basically picks up the slack and
says okay like we know that that planet
Earth basically has like this seed and
this seed will give birth to like four
trees and whichever one of these trees
grows that's the Omega Titan that's
going to be coming here to destroy the
planet and so for her it's really like
trying to understand what's going on
really more so than any
yes and that's kind of the crazy thing
when it comes to Amanda Waller she's
ruthless in a lot of ways she'll do
whatever she needs to do in order to get
the information she needs the issue with
this is that while she's poking around
she's basically met by Green Arrow by
Oliver Queen now his arrival here to
confront Amanda Waller is really an
indication of just how dire things are
but Before we jump into that I want to
switch over to planet colu
which is where we actually ended up end
up traveling to and it's kind of crazy
because this giant Omega Titan is
basically just standing there biding its
time getting ready to consume the world
now this is one of the things to bear in
mind when it comes to situations like
this when you have beings of such
immense power one of the things that
come in book companies and one of the
things writers will do is they'll
basically kind of transpose time and
they'll say well you know to this being
time passes differently if you have a
being who's been alive for billions and
billions of years then like the passage
of a few minutes or an hour is basically
irrelevant to them it's it's the blink
of an eye and the time it takes for this
Omega Titan to arrive to begin the
process of consuming the world for it to
finish consuming the world and then
leave as far as its own mega Titans
concern it amounts to whatever what's
basically seconds but for everybody here
who's looking at this event unfold it
seems to take a couple hours or
something like that and so the other
part of this is that in their mind it's
just a matter of basically getting
through and trying to figure out what
brainiacs plan is because basically
Brainiac was destroyed before they
figured it all out all they knew is that
brainiacs split them into teams for a
reason and that's it that's the only
thing they really have to go on but in
the middle of this they're suddenly met
by the immersion of these giant trees
now this is where things really begin to
kick in this is where we really started
to get this explanation the way this
works is you've got four Omega Titans
and we talked about them before you
basically have wisdom chaos mystery and
an entropy and the idea is that these
Omega Titans will show up to a planet
that's basically in direct relation to
whatever that Omega Titan is so in this
instance four trees do crop up on this
planet but the wisdom tree is the one
that's actually growing and immersed
with energy and what that means is that
this planet is more conducive to wisdom
it's kind of a way to sort of create a
signal to say this is the Omega type
that's gonna be coming here kind of
firing a flare so to speak into the air
now right off the bat and this is
exactly what to expect this is one of
the reasons why Scott Snyder writing is
so cool
Scott Snyder is just like this master at
writing about characters and that's what
works he's such a good character writer
much sinestro for example I mean as far
as I'm aware
Scott Snyder's never written Breen
but his ability to write sinestro here
is exactly what we would expect because
when you have basically Batman who says
look we don't know what brainiacs plan
is brainiacs always been a bad guy we
can't trust him we're gonna reform these
teams in our own image and then we're
gonna go forward the first thing
Sinestro says is like I lead armies of
people I'm not a follower and I'm not
following anybody here and it works
perfect it fits in perfectly with this
story but then you have Martian
Manhunter and you have Lex Luthor and
that's why this is cool
because Lex Luthor basically chimes in
and says all of you guys are acting like
idiots right now Brainiac like whether
you want to admit it or not
Brainiac this the version of Brainiac
that brought us here and every version
of Brainiac that exists out there is way
ahead of us we're sitting on a planet of
the smartest people to ever exist in the
history of the universe basically we've
been brought here by a version of
Brainiac that's smarter than all of
these people and is certainly smarter
than us yet somehow you think it makes
sense to you to believe that you know
better than Brainiac test he split us
into teams for a reason we should act
accordingly and that's awesome it's so
cool here and that's one of the reasons
why I like Lex Luthor right now in DC
rebirth Lex Luthor is is really kind of
being moved in the direction of going
back to being a bad guy which is kind of
disappointing because him being a good
guy is was like a huge break away from
the status quo and there's been so much
great riding with that whole thing but
regardless what stance DC takes when it
comes to the character of Lex Luthor the
consistent factor has always been that
Lex Luthor is exceedingly smart and when
it comes down to it if you have to make
the choice of whether or not Lex Luthor
is on your team it's not even an
argument of you know being on the
devil's right hand than in his path it's
a matter of he's a guy that's got it
where it counts he's got the brain and
he's a guy you definitely want like him
or Batman and so that's kind of the cool
thing is while he's not necessarily
viewed by everybody as a legitimate
superhero despite the fact that he tries
to be at the end of the day they're like
but it is Lex Luthor and like he is
pretty damn smart so we should probably
listen to him if so Batman kind of
responds by somebody saying well as long
as there's a member of the Justice
League on each team then we can go along
with this plan and we can do whatever we
have to do at this point we switch over
to like the team's traveling to the four
trees entropy wonder mystery wisdom and
it's kind of cool here because what we
end up finding out is kind of what we
knew before in the sense that like the
wisdom tree is the one that's really
really growing in this because of the
fact that Omega Titan is here is the one
tree they kind of have to figure
everything out for it but for the other
ones what we ended up finding out or
as it was explained by Brainiac to the
group was that diesel mega Titans
basically arrived here because one tree
is that is essentially like outgrowing
all the others meaning that the world
needs to be consumed but the idea is
basically jumpstart all four trees get
all four trees growing back to where
they need to be and then you can
basically send the omega Titans off at
least that seems to be the case either
that or I guess all four omega Titans
would show up here and consume the whole
planet I have no idea but because only
one omega Titan can consume a planet at
any point in time and then having one
true having one planet to consist of all
four trees seems to be the best step to
take but remember they're basically just
like running on guesses and hearsay
there's no absolute guarantee that this
will even work they're just going based
on what they believe to be right and so
as they're going through and as they're
investigating various things it is cool
here because what ends up happening is
that once they basically get to the tree
that deals with like you know what deals
with mystery they start to go through
and realize this tree is basically
filled with planets and this really
feeds into the nature of what Brainiac
did right like you know DC kind of
modified the origin of Brainiac in the
new 52 and the sense of what you saw was
that there was a you know a giant group
that was leaving the fifth dimension and
they were traveling around the universe
and they were you know or at least
traveling around various places and
destroying entire worlds and the
original brainiacs idea was well we can
save this from happening by like saving
pieces of worlds and that was the reason
why he would travel from one world to
the next and like take sections of it
and throw it into a bottle what's been
going on here his entire worlds have
been bottled now this is the
world-building part this is actually one
of the smartest things I've seen done
the idea is in the question they have is
if we're going to basically get this
tree going it's much like the fifth
element right you know what those those
different those different you know
Brooks whatever it is fire to fire water
to water win to win dirt to dirt you
know it's that whole situation if you
never saw Fifth Element don't worry
about that but that's basically what's
going on here they have to create
mystery they have to create chaos they
have to create a circumstance where no
one knows what's going to happen and the
best way to do that is to free all these
worlds but these are worlds of races
that have long since they all had that
that had long since believed to have
been extinct no one in the modern era
has even seen these and they don't even
know what's on these worlds they have no
idea what's here but that's the basis
it's the risk they have to release them
all but the cool thing about this is
that is kind of Scott Snyder saying well
if all these worlds are released then
that's all stuff that we haven't seen
before and it's all stuff that we can
write about in the future of DC Comics
and where everybody kind of debates the
pros and cons we have no
what could take place here different
people have different motivations
despite the fact that these motivations
may be altruistic or they may be selfish
the fact remains they can basically free
these worlds the problem with this is
that they can't pull it off and the
reason why they can't pull it off is
there's a somewhat somewhat of a
disruption field that comes from like
each one of these trees and so that's
that's where they start to run into the
caveat of like they have to have
Brainiac because they can't get into any
one of these devices they can't actually
implement the plant and so we're each
member of the Justice League teams you
know communicates with the other and
tells them what's going on they're all
running into the exact same circumstance
they're reaching what amounts to
basically an invisible wall and they
can't pull it off and so in response to
all this while it's all going on
suddenly this voice chimes out of
nowhere and simply says did you guys
really believe it was gonna be that
simple that these are mega Titans whose
shrubs of these planets would basically
create a system that anybody could
disrupt and then in turn just allow to
though allow for their defeat and so
what this guy basically says is like
there's nothing you can do here this
planet's dead there never was anything
you could ever do about it worry I
didn't bring you here because he
believes you guys can genuinely stop
this he brought you here because he
wanted your powers and we end up finding
out the person that's basically
revealing all this is real is its world
ox2
Brainiac to point out this is kind of
crazy here because as far as I'm aware
in DC college we have not seen Brainiac
2 in new 52 like like post 2011 he's not
been in DC Comics since before the new
52 launched now the way that's
originally worked out and he goes
although he goes way back like he's he
was even before crisis on Infinite
Earths but the way this played out
originally was that vril dox - or
Brainiac 2.0 was like this son of
Brainiac now in some stories in the the
really old free crisis stories it was
just a kid he adopted the Brainiac
adopted basically and like kind of
raised him to turn him into the new
Brainiac and like more modern stories it
was basically just a version created by
the original Brainiac but the consistent
factor here and really the more modern
stories is it like Brainiac 2.0 never
really saw himself as his father he did
not want to be like his dad and so
that's where things get kind of hairy
here is we don't know what this version
of Brainiac 2.0 is gonna be is it gonna
be post-crisis version between 1986 and
2011 where he's basically more of a hero
than anything else or is he gonna be
just like the original Brainiac where
he's a bad
Gai now but because of the fact that
this is DC rebirth and it's basically
designed to bring back a lot of things
from before 2011 I would err on the side
of caution and say he's probably a good
guy and he's gonna be the one saving
grace and this seems to be evidenced by
the fact that like the Justice League
teams need a version of Brainiac to pull
this off and for the most part I don't
really see any other any other version
of Brainiac coming back so the nature of
Scott Snyder storytelling isn't really
to focus on like one thing so I believe
there's probably gonna be a lot more
surprises in store as the story goes on
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]